look at this under five minutes for your
cash against 31 minutes Magnus working
his endgame magic now everything is
working in Perfection just as Magnus had
imagined with the G5 and then it turns
out that Luke G5 was indeed a very
strong move not a mistake
yeah I think Lucas needed four hours on
the clock let alone four minutes to find
that ingenious defense with Rook A5
giving up the pawn and running with the
white king towards the king side King C2
lucasri and then the design yeah that's
possible
oh no it's been a tough game I mean ever
since the opening which we were praising
him for ever since that kind of led to
this slightly slower end game with the
imbalance and lack with a better
structure
I mean he's not made any blunders go
cash but there we go he does fall to
defeat Magnus takes the win
and only needs a draw with the white
pieces tomorrow to progress to the
semi-finals
yeah very smooth Yeah by Magnus and what
a smooth victory